J no
dad my name is Barry Allen I love John
do I know you you're not wearing your
rings things must be different here hey
everybody it's Charlie this is gonna be
my Elseworlds
episode 2 video so many Easter eggs
obviously focusing more on the Batman
characters inside the DC Universe with a
really big Green Lantern bomb that was a
pretty fun surprise paying off a big fan
question from a long time ago on arrow
we're doing a new round of that flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment on the video so top 10
WTF and all the comic book Easter eggs
starting with number 10
Barry's Elseworlds intro I love the way
they play this like he's been arrow all
this time like they do it before the
recap of Elseworlds like he just got out
of prison just got in that big fight
with Diaz they did not do that for the
first episode of the crossover with
Stephen Amell like he just wakes up and
is like what what the hell is going on
so this time they're playing it like
Barry has been Green Arrow for the last
seven seasons 9 Jericho is the new
Deathstroke so they don't explain
whether or not this is a consequence of
Deegan changing reality the first time
or if this would have happened anyway
but if you haven't been watching arrow
for the last couple of seasons Jericho
was introduced last season on arrow
during season 6 when they had a two-part
Deathstroke episode but because he's
wearing the original Deathstroke costume
I'm assuming that he's taken the mantle
from his father they come back to Argus
there's a really funny moment where
Diggle recites all of the biggest plot
twists from the earlier crossovers going
back to the first one I guess I
shouldn't be surprised now with all the
crazy stuff we've been through all these
separate years they pay off the funny
wife swap moment with Felicity this time
because now Barry is technically married
to her and they have like this awkward
conversation it's a bit of a carryover
from the arrow plot this season but
probably one of the funniest ones number
8 Oliver doesn't think that Batman is
real Batman is a myth created by the
Gotham City Police Department of course
Barry who loves comic book heroes as a
child would think that Batman was real
they go to Gotham on the rooftop they
shot this in Chicago in real life so
Stephen Amell was saying that they got
to go to a brand new city that he's
never filmed in before so Chicago was
where they filmed the Dark Knight
trilogy so I don't know if they're going
to continue to try and film there for
the Batwoman
TV show or
they're gonna film that in Vancouver I
would assume that they would try to film
it in a different City so that it looks
different from Central City or Star City
but they're not supposed to film the
pilot for the Batwoman show till April
so we probably won't find out about that
for a while they make a whole bunch of
jokes about Oliver getting so much tail
in the early seasons of arrow Barry says
one time he cheated on his girlfriend
with her sister talking about Laura and
Sara Lance so even though they weren't
part of the crossover there were a lot
of references to some of those
characters like when they get thrown in
jail they try to call the district
attorney black siren and she says to
just let them rot in jail for the night
7 this is actually a big one tie a
couple big DC movie Easter eggs to the
arrowverse so they find the bat-signal
and they're near a Wayne Enterprises
building where Bruce Wayne's main
company used to be but here's the thing
though the logo on the Wayne Enterprises
building is the logo from The Dark
Knight trilogy so it's like they're
trying to say with a couple different
Easter eggs that their version of Earth
one Batman is the Christian Bale Batman
which i think is a solid bet in terms of
how old he would be at this point and
how old Kate Cain bat woman is and all
these other characters but they start
this running joke where Barry starts to
taunt Oliver with how awesome he thinks
that Batman is because Oliver still
wants to believe like he's the first
vigilante when he says that - that's
more of a joke about how arrow was the
first show and that's why we call it the
arrow verse because all the other shows
are spin-offs of arrow technically and
they do finally explain where he's been
and what's been going on in Gotham like
they call it basically a trash pile like
don't come to Gotham it is the worst
place ever number 6
Oliver explains what happened to the
Batman so Oliver says Bruce Wayne left
Gotham three years ago very publicly no
one knows why and he hasn't been seen
since and when he left the Wayne
Enterprises board got sucked into a
bunch of get-rich-quick schemes and
everything went to [ __ ] on a corporate
level and with the city's infrastructure
so if you think that crime and
everything in Star City is bad this
season it's way worse in Gotham since
Batman left things have just gone to
complete [ __ ] which provides the really
compelling reason for bat woman to be so
active and she does kind of explain what
she's doing and a lot of that will be
paid off during the
woman TV show so there are a lot of
setups and previews for characters that
will appear during that but Batwoman
introduces herself Kate Kane everything
that she says about her character like
I'm Bruce Wayne's cousin that's all
right out of the comics so they're being
very authentic to that she and Cara even
have a bonding moment over having
cousins that are way more famous than
them so bat woman's more famous cousin
that everybody loves way more is Batman
super girl's way more famous cousin that
everybody loves more is Superman there
were a couple world's finest comic book
references for Batman Superman I'm
assuming that because even though she's
on earth one bat woman will cross over
more with Supergirl then she will with
the other shows in the future but a lot
of that just depends on how long each of
the show's stays on the air but because
she's on earth one it's a lot easier for
her to cross over with Oliver and Barry
so we'll just see what ends up happening
with that there was a really cool Easter
Egg when Cara is talking to her she
pulls out the bust of Shakespeare The
Bard himself and that's an Easter Egg
for the Batman 1966 Adam West TV series
is basically the secret entrance to the
Batcave but the bust was inside Wayne
Manor on the Adam West TV series so it
shows up in his office here they have a
really funny moment trying to break into
Arkham Asylum using killer frost oh
she's crazy she freezes stuff oh yeah we
have a couple of those in here just
making a reference to mr. freeze which
they paid off later in the episode with
a couple different Easter eggs but
number 5 all the big Batman villains in
Arkham Asylum so if you slowed down the
frames or you replayed the scene you
could see all the name plates on the
prison cells it's the penguin then
poison ivy then the basil Karlo Clayface
the Riddler
like he says what's blue and green and
red all over then the last cell is
actually pretty meta because it's Marc
Guggenheim former showrunner on arrow in
the person that I think wrote most of
the crossover episodes I don't know if
he wrote every single episode of the
crossover but he definitely had a big
hand in them the person that says the
inmates are finally running the asylum
and puts the gold mask on is
psycho-pirate who then gets taken down
by a bat woman he'll probably come back
around at the end probably some post
credit scene tag because he's a really
important figure for a crisis on
Infinite Earths that woman's showing up
to try and stop the Prison Break is a
good example of what her abilities and
what hurt
knowledge is gonna look like the way her
Batarang works on her spin-off show but
like I said they were teasing characters
that would show up on her show pretty
much any big Batman villain that you saw
referenced during this episode is
probably fair game for her TV show
because right now the Gotham TV show
which has most of those characters is
going off the air after a next season
like they're doing their final run and
then I'm assuming that they're gonna get
all those characters inside the
arrowverse but like she says that she
has a person that used to work with
Wayne in the R&D department that's still
there like she's making a Lucius Fox
reference but I don't actually think
that it's him I think that it's a
different character that's rumored for
her TV show that'll wind up being the
comic book batwing character so yes
there will be other bat family members
on the Batwoman TV show but I think the
batwing is supposed to be the next big
one because two of the Robins and maybe
three eventually are on the Titans TV
show and technically that's in a
different universe we also get to meet
Nora fries who breaks out of her cold
storage device like it just basically
shuts down so she starts freaking out
trying to find a way to reactivate it
because of her degenerative condition
when she's wrestling through that supply
room when killer frost walks in you see
the bane mask from Dark Knight Rises
like I said they're trying to canonize
the events of the Dark Knight trilogy in
Christian Bale's Batman to the
arrowverse she finally grabs her
husband's mr. Freeze's gun but here's
the thing it's Arnold Schwarzenegger ice
gun from Batman and Robin so it's kind
of a funny Easter Egg because the minute
you recognize it all you can think about
is all the crazy puns from that movie
most of you also probably recognized
that Nora freeze is being played by
Stephen amell's wife in real life but
the funny thing is is that the way they
get rid of her is is that Stephen
amell's flash runs up and throws
lightning at her so it's Stephen Amell
throwing lightning at his wife in real
life
number four though Oliver accidentally
knocks over a bunch of fear toxin
canisters and they start fighting each
other Barry and Oliver but they're
hallucinating each other as each other's
worst enemies so Barry is fighting
Merlyn because he has all of his life so
he's fighting Oliver's worst villain and
it's the same for Oliver who has to
fight the reverse-flash and they use it
as a way to give them some common ground
like oh I understand some of the things
that you've gone through in your life
number three this is a really awesome
one 90s Barry Allen
breaches through completely and explains
everything but also lets us know that
earth ninety diggle is John Stuart or a
version of John Stuart part of the Green
Lantern Corps so if you haven't been
watching arrow or you haven't been part
of the fandom since way back in season
one that was one of the earliest things
that fans wonder would Diggle be able to
become a Green Lantern at some point
because everybody wondered if he would
get a superhero persona it was before
they gave him that weird helmet in the
guardian persona but of course because
Ric Lantern is a really big movie
franchise Warner Brothers would never
let the arrow verse use any big Green
Lantern stuff just Easter Egg level at
best like way back in season four we got
the Hal Jordan name tag on screen for a
couple frames that in Carol Farris --iz
airfield in Central City is the closest
we've ever gotten to actual Green
Lantern in the air overs so even though
the ones that we know about are only in
earth 90 that means that there are
corresponding ones in our earth one
universe hopefully someday we'll be able
to see some of them on screen but the
way that 90s Barry Allen explains what
the book is all about and what the
monitor is doing is that he's testing
different realities trying to find one
that's strong enough to stand against an
even greater threat which is a reference
to the anti-monitor for crisis on
Infinite Earths in the comics so as
suspected most you probably guess that
this is what's going on because the
monitor is actually a hero in the comics
so he gives the book back to Deegan in
number one you changes reality a second
time this time Barry and Oliver are the
trigger twins which is a really deep cut
comic book team but they don't have
their powers and the central city police
catch them and the police officers just
happened to be Jericho Malcolm Merlyn in
Ricardo Diaz to take them in and even
though they get away we finally meet
black suit Superman we only get a little
teaser for him but he seems like a
completely separate character from our
normal earth 38 Superman because we see
both of them fighting each other during
part 3 which will air tomorrow night so
everybody let me know in the comments
what was your favorite moment and your
favorite Easter Egg my part 3 video will
post tomorrow night click here for all
my Elseworlds
Easter eggs so far and click here for my
brand new spider-man far
home teaser breakdown thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]